on vous parle maintenant du monarque pas
le roi mais bien sûr comme vous le voyez
le papillon dont la survie est de plus
en plus menacée à la fois par
l'agriculture au canada et aux
états-unis et lé confort et sert au
mexique et un sommet actuellement à
mexico avec les trois chefs d'état il
pourrait en être question
michel rechange alors voilà ces petites
capsules eu toute délicate cash papillon
en devenir
c'est une chrysalide à horizon d'un
morceau elle alors c'est la forme
intermédiaire entre la chenille et le
papillon
je prépare quelques accrochages qui
donneront naissance d'ici quelques
semaines à deux magnifiques papillons
il est rond rejoindre les 20 mille
autres que les équipes de l'insectarium
et du jardin botanique préparent pour
leur exposition papillons en liberté
elle est pétillante des ambassadeurs
extraordinaires pour les insectes donc
ça nous permet de parler de toutes
sortes de comportements et d'enjeux
aussi autour des 1 6 passes à travers le
monde par le biais des pétitions le
papillon monarque par exemple est au
coeur d'un enjeu économique important
sa grande migration entre le canada les
états unis et le mexique est compromise
il n'y en avait presque plus l'été
dernier au canada raison la forêt
mexicaine où il hiverne et illégalement
déboisé l'asclépiade de la plante sur
laquelle ils se reproduisent se nourrit
disparaît tout au long de sa route
migratoire à cause du maïs et du soya
transgénique et d'herbicides cette
semaine la rencontre des leaders des
trois pays serait une chance d'en
arriver à un accord de coopération pour
sauver les monarques
il ya une urgence il ya une réelle
urgence en ce moment il ya des mesures à
entreprendre
et oui il faut que les états en soit
conscient je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui est déjà été plus
à leur agenda un petit peu moins
maintenant contrairement à bien des
problèmes environnementaux
les citoyens peuvent agir facilement au
canada le papillon monarque a tout
simplement besoin d'ascq les piannencs
de planter l'asclépiade ya l'asclépiade
comme il ya d'autres dossiers piano
québec aussi qu'on peut qu'on te planter
sauver le monarque disent les
biologistes c'est de travailler pour
sauvegarder tous les papillons en
liberté
ici michel rochon radio canada montréal